oh my god how many other so you have to
ask your questions while stuff like this
is a distractor you give
hey guys it's Henry goldenhair from
crazy rotations and BuzzFeed gave me
kittens house for kittens I think one of
those kitten cafes or cafe I have a
obscene fascination with cats it's kind
of embarrassing if this took you this
one week you either that or flying out
somewhere like Disneyland I hate crowds
so just breeding family and friends over
there and having a good time without
having to queue and then filling the
entire place with cats and dogs and
puppies go say Jimmy O yang plays Burnet
I extremely well the obnoxious cousin
with ridiculous amounts of money that
would be a fun well if not aquafina
kills as people in that would have been
a wicked or I don't know about the wig
though that was that looks pretty
achieved nobody wants to play with me I
got you
oh I think I was like it's been that for
I've got photos where I was very young
so just holding pipe to cats and
actually one of those photos I put up on
Instagram and he got me a movie role
this is bringing back memories no escape
[Music]
john scoured pretty much the entire
world for asian acting man when I got
the news I was having this furious fight
on Valentine's Day with my wife I get
the call is John everything stops and he
told me the great news and obviously the
rest of the day went really well I think
was just that that family camaraderie we
were with such a tight-knit group every
single night we go out for dinner we'd
we'd hang out I'd show him around KL or
Singapore and we're all that together
Asians from America from the UK from
Australia from Malaysia and Singapore
was really special
these Gibbons what'd you miss Michelle
yeah Michelle Yeoh is the biggest
amazing female Asian star in the
universe she was Queen on and off the
set so classy so down to her every
morning she'd she'd come on set she'd
like to hug everyone from the grips the
lighting to so that the actors to all
the ADEs that's exactly how you want to
move start where she was priceless I
love
I think John chose Ben Hill Annette when
it comes to being sort of Asian leading
man a lot of films like he's producing
his own movies telling his own stories
Angley he is like amazing so I think
doing a film with Langley would be
breathtaking
there was so much fun behind me I've
coached him into being okay you know in
the core of it like Nick is a really
well-traveled guy he puts family and
love first before family riches and I
think he just wants to do the right
thing he sees the error of his ways and
he tries to make amends for Rachel he's
got a kitten but in my face it was a
little silly and not preparing Rachel
maybe was afraid of something this guy
trying to escape don't do it he wants to
be independent and not have to rely on
being this add this ridiculous family
throne I guess we have that in common
I definitely don't have the bank account
like I wish that was something perhaps
was available
I don't believe in having regrets just
think of it as a learning process I've
never let anything get me down otherwise
you're just gonna have bad vibes
negative energy
let it go be like a kid and forget about
it so if you guys are interested in
adopting any of these really cute
kittens please go to Best Friends Animal
Society and like best friends or they
will offer the option adopt don't shop
[Music]
alright baby
[Music]